the circle stars Emma Watson Tom Hanks
and John boyega and Patton Oswalt
encompass the spectacular now a romance
film that I thought was definitely
above-average in regards to romance
movies and this movie is about a company
that at first I thought was a cult I had
really no idea what this movie was about
when I saw the trailer and I went in
thinking it was a cult but it's actually
more of like a Google mashup between
social media and Google where a whole
bunch of people work in this big agency
called the circle it's just very modern
now hip place where anybody with an idea
can be the next Albert Einstein and
everybody is respected but everyone's
also connected people at the circle
including Emma Watson who's just gotten
a job there are all encouraged to go on
their social media accounts and let
everybody know what everyone's doing and
eventually Emma Watson's character she's
like you know what I'm going to go fully
transparent she puts cameras on herself
she lets everybody know exactly what
she's doing
and every single time of day safer when
she uses the restroom and Tom Hanks and
Patton Oswalt are the leaders of this
organization you can tell that as the
film goes along the increasing amount of
transparency the fact that they're
putting cameras everywhere to catch
people catch criminals catch child
predators you can see the positives but
you can also see where it would lead
towards invasion of privacy and a lot of
other rights issues and eventually of
course some drama ensues and we have a
film a very bad film but it is a film so
I guess there were some screenings of
the circle in other places because when
I logged onto my computer today I saw
that other people had reviewed the movie
and I guess maybe in LA or New York
there were some screenings but here at
Ohio there were none absolutely no
advance screenings for critics and for a
movie with Tom Hanks and Emma Watson and
John boyega that's not a good time I
left this movie I know this movie is a
complete mess from the beginning to the
end
there is one incident one moment of
tension one and it was so poorly edited
just like the rest of the film is that
it basically left memory instantaneously
what am I getting at I'm getting at that
this film is boring really nothing
happens in this movie we have a
character played by Emma Watson who is a
perfectly fine actress when she's given
the right role
but in this movie she is very flat and
very monotone and is basically OneNote
throughout the entire film and Tom Hanks
the master of charisma one of my
favorite actors is basically in the
movie for one scene for the first hour
and then is scattered throughout the
rest of the movie it's really really
crappy marketing that he's on the poster
and in all the trailers is like this big
part of the movie when he's in the film
but barely he kind of is like let's say
mmm puts out a new album and on the
cover of Eminem's album you see Eminem
in the background you see Kendrick Lamar
and you're like holy is this them
on the album together collaborating
that's amazing and then you go to the
album and you realize that one song is
featuring Kendrick Lamar and maybe he
had like a little bit of a chorus kind
of in the background maybe like it's
like that like Tom Hanks is like that
that's that's my example using talented
rappers John boyega is in the film even
less and it was funny because Emma
Watson's character was so poorly written
and so bland that whenever John boyega
or Tom Hanks or Patton Oswalt popped up
I was like okay let's get some let's get
some charisma going here because as I
said Tom Hanks master charisma even him
in this film he's kind of OneNote too
and a lot of it comes down to the
direction which I must admit is fairly
bad it's a sleek-looking movie you can
tell that professional people were on
this crew filming and recording the
sound and doing all those things but the
way the film was cut together the shot
structure in particular and the use of
some really obvious ADR and some very
bad accents as well really make this
film feel more amateur than it is
because obviously the people working on
it are not amateur but for whatever
reason the final product has that feel
the editing in this movie is so bad that
there's one scene in particular that
really stood out to me it's a scene in
the bathroom where emma watson and her
friend they're both talking to each
other in separate stalls but they used
the exact same standard angle amid
pretty much with emma watson and her
friend exactly centered in the shop and
as they cut between stalls they
basically mimic the exact same angle so
it almost looks like
emma watson and her friend are
essentially teleporting like jump
cutting
in and out of the exact same stall even
though it's different stalls and this
scene goes on for like three or four
minutes and it was really abrasive to
anybody who really likes to pay
attention to editing and I know most of
you guys do and so when that scene comes
just be like wow they're just Emma
Watson his jump cutting between toilet
seats the characters in this movie that
I thought had the most to them were
actually her parents and they're
featured from time to time Bill Paxton
and his final film role rest in peace it
was so sad to see him I out what I
actually forgot he was in this movie
because I had seen him on the credits
list on IMDB and when I saw him in movie
I was like ah man damn it oh it was sad
but um he plays somebody with MS in this
film and his wife is caring for him and
trying to help him throughout his
illness and they're also very curious
about her new job Emma Watson's and they
have things to say that as audience
members you're like yeah that's yeah
that that's what I'm curious about - how
comes you don't notice this main
protagonist hero that we're supposed to
relate to and so I found myself siding
with her parents quite often and being
like man those are the most interesting
characters in the movie I don't know I'm
just weird I got obviously today
technology is pretty advanced we're
seeing more and more things developed
every single day and there's always that
point where you're like wow it's privacy
now gone as I see Facebook live and
periscope and all these things it's like
okay at what point do we just sit back
and maybe go on a vacation by ourselves
you know do we have to share everything
is everything shareable and this movie
has some of those nuggets of fear that I
think a lot of people feel in regards to
technology but it takes it to such an
absurd level we're like hundreds of
people thousands millions even billions
actually is the number we get thrown at
at one point in this movie who are
totally invested in this new idea
that's just so absurd that I can't
possibly believe anyone would actually
invest themselves in its complete and
total lack of privacy and a horrific
invasion of it yet everyone's like yes
yes it's great politicians that
everybody and I'm like okay you lost me
and at that point in the movie you're
just waiting for the shoe to drop or
something terrible to happen for
everybody to learn their lesson and then
things go back to normal but the film
no spoilers doesn't really have much of
a resolution because it also doesn't set
up a conflict that's the biggest issue I
have with this movie is that it tries to
get dramatic towards the last final few
scenes but they never set up a conflict
you just have a bunch of little moments
or like oh that seems a little too
invasion of privacy issue me and that's
it there's no real antagonist there's
barely a protagonist there's barely a
conflict there's hardly any character
choices just a whole bunch of people who
constantly gives speeches who have ideas
about products imagine the scene in
civil war where Tony Stark is talking to
all the students and gives them grants
and he shows off some of his technology
and then amplify that by like 50 percent
of the movie that's the circle there are
so many scenes where Tom Hanks or Emma
Watson are just standing in front of a
crowd presenting an idea and sometimes
it goes wrong and sometimes it doesn't
there's no conflict this film just kind
of deflates within itself so bland
performances from very talented actors
pretty boring direction from a very
talented director and awful editing this
is one of those Hollywood movies where
you're like yeah I see why so many
people want to make independent movies
now because if this is what it's like oh
I'm going to give the circle a D the
best part of this film for me was that I
got to have my first bag of popcorn in
over a year I got my braces off so that
was nice I just got to sit down some
popcorn it was just delicious because I
mean you guys know how many movies I go
to and I don't love popcorn like I'm not
a huge popcorn guy but once you can't
have something it's like oh my god I
want popcorn and then you can't have it
and then you're kind of screwed but I
finally caught some today it was so
great also I want to make sure you guys
know that I am still running my
promotion with audible.com if you go to
audible.com slash Chris you can get a
free 30 day trial and a free audiobook
this is a fantastic service for people
who love reading but don't always have
the time to read a physical book and
sometimes they need to listen to a book
at their jobs or on a plane or wherever
on their various tablets and mobile
devices they
have hundreds of thousands of copies of
pretty much anything you could imagine
in regards to that
and a lot of you have mentioned to me
that you have used this service for
schoolbooks and things like that because
they also have school books on there as
well it's not just the fictional
entertainment and like I said it's a
great service I have listened to a lot
of Star Wars novels student kings and my
favorite author pretty much all this
stuff is on there too I'm currently
reading through mr. Mercedes and it's
amazing guys thank you very much for
watching and definitely go to
audible.com slash Chris and check out
that free trial for 30 days and a free
audio book you guys are the best as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Manoj
[Music]